[Music]
if you traveled to the deepest points of
earth
what would you find lost cities
mythical sea monsters rivers of gold
probably not but there's still a lot to
discover
so join me as we travel deep
underneath the surface to explore some
of the most
inhospitable places on earth
what lives at the bottom of the mariana
trench
how much of the ocean is unmapped
and what is mined deep below the earth's
surface
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you explored the deepest points on
earth
not many people can claim that they've
been to the deepest points on earth but
victor viscovocan from 2018 to
2019 viscovo led an
expedition that visited the deepest
points in
all five oceans the five deeps
expedition covered 87 000 kilometers in
just
10 months and completed 39
dives using a small submarine for your
trip
you're only going to visit one trench
the mariana trench
you'll need to save about three quarters
of a million dollars for the trip
but you'd be one of the few people to
explore
this deep what would you see
as you descend first you'd need to
travel to japan
from there you'd take a submarine about
2
000 kilometers out into the pacific
ocean
challenger deep the deepest point of the
mariana trench
is almost 11 kilometers below the
surface
and it would take about two and a half
hours to reach it
there will be a lot to look at in the
beginning of your descent
the first 200 meters below the surface
is where
most ocean life thrives as you travel
deeper it becomes darker and the less
wildlife you'd see though you'd still
get to witness the occasional whale
diving for food
you'd see your first deep sea creature
the fang tooth
at one kilometer below the surface this
appropriately named fish is 16
centimeters long with
two giant teeth to make room for them
the fangtooth has two sockets beside its
brain
as you travel deeper than 2500 meters
there are no more whales they don't
usually dive down this deep
but when you hit 8 000 meters
you'd encounter the mariana snailfish at
this point
the atmospheric pressure is nearly 1100
times what you feel at sea
level if you weren't inside a
pressurized submarine
it would be like having the weight of a
fully loaded truck
on your head those little snail fish out
there must be
pretty strong to withstand all this
intense pressure
eventually you'd reach the very bottom
the challenger deep
if you look closely you might spot an
amphipod species
a rhonda leia gigas these small
deep ocean creatures are only about
three centimeters long
and that's about it down in the mariana
trench
no secret treasures hidden cities or sea
monsters
next it's time for you to travel to the
world's deepest sea volcano
the west mata volcano this underwater
site
is located southwest of the samoas
you'll need to rent another submarine to
travel down
1200 meters below the surface
but since you just visited the mariana
trench it should be no problem for you
if you're lucky the volcano would be
active
and you would enjoy seeing lava
fountains and glowing bubbles
just be careful of all the debris that
erupts into the ocean
both the west mata volcano and the
mariana trench
are natural deep points on earth but
what about something that's man-made
the penang gold mine is the deepest
operating mind in the world around 4
000 miners work in it every day
and despite safety precautions it's
still risky
in march 2020 a seismic event killed
three miners who were three and a half
kilometers below the surface
to get to the mine you'd need to travel
to the gauteng province in south africa
you'd take the elevator known as a cage
with 119 other workers
until it reaches two and a half
kilometers below the earth's surface
as the elevator doors open you'll notice
the heat
it's about 30 degrees and that's only
because the mining company has created a
system to cool down the air
without fans blowing over a mixture of
ice and salt
the mine would be a whopping 60 degrees
why because you're so deep in the earth
that its inner heat is warming up the
surrounding atmosphere
you'd only be two and a half kilometers
underneath the earth's surface
to go lower you'd need to walk or drive
the rest of the way
you'd be at the bottom of the mine when
you reached
4 kilometers that's as deep
as 10 empire state buildings
luckily there are no cave creatures to
worry about down here
the only life down here other than the
miners is
monotypic bacteria while the
opening gold mine is impressive
all of the deepest points on earth are
in
oceans according to nasa over
80 percent of the oceans remain unmapped
unobserved and unexplored and
if we want to continue to explore these
areas we're going to need to take better
care
of our planet for starters we could
clean up our trash filled oceans can you
imagine a mariana trench just brimming
with garbage
well that's a story for another
what if
[Music]
you